Scott why movies
[Music]
great question
as someone who lived in a household
that was very
Sports oriented growing up
I had a very big disconnect with my
father
because he always wanted me to play
baseball or football
and I was always that quirky kid who
liked to draw and sit down and watch
Sesame Street
and then I discovered movies
and movies
were an escape
they made me forget about things that
were going on in my home
they made me
Escape into different worlds they made
me feel things they inspired me
and I credit Tim Burton
for why I do what I do today because yes
I grew up watching Pee-wee's Playhouse
but it wasn't until peewee's Big
Adventure
and then
Beetlejuice and Batman that I really
became obsessed with movies
and my world changed entirely when I saw
Tim Burton's Nightmare Before Christmas
that movie spoke to me on so many levels
and it made me love the gothic culture
it made me fall in love with stop-motion
animation
but it opened my mind
in such a way
that I never quite experienced before
I this became so obsessed with this
movie that I bought there was this art
book that came out from it and I would
take it everywhere you know I go go to
the dinner table I had goes for the the
art book I would
bring it into the bathroom I was just
obsessed with this book so much so
that it actually made me want to draw
and there was a period of time in my
life where I actually thought I wanted
to become an animator
and I took animation classes
because of this book because of this
movie
and it really just made me fall in love
with
movies animation and the entire thing as
an art form
what's the favorite scene from Nightmare
Before Christmas
laughs
I mean it's right from the beginning I I
mean Nightmare Before Christmas has such
an iconic opening scene with the Patrick
Stewart voiceover
This Is Halloween I mean all of those
characters coming to life whether it's
lock shock and barrel Oogie Boogie Jack
Skellington Sally all of them coming to
life just
I don't know this like warp kid life
just was like inspired almost the same
way like you feel with Tim Burton's
background right he was a weird recluse
he was like the social outcast and he
just he drew these weird characters and
these weird drawings
and everyone was kind of like what's up
with you growing up and I was not a
popular kid
and watching this movie I felt seen it
was very weird because Jack Skellington
in a weird way lives in this world this
Halloween Town
but then he won something more
and he he wants to become Santa Claus he
wants the he wants something different
he yearns for change
and I think I resonated with that
not really realizing it as a kid that
I wasn't like a lot of people my age and
that I always wanted something different
I wanted to be viewed differently and
this movie just spoke to me in a way
that I really can't describe
what other movies have changed her life
well in addition The Nightmare Before
Christmas
there's been a lot of them that impacted
me in different ways throughout the
years
again I I feel like the ultimate Timber
and Fanboy here but
between peewee's big adventure
Beetlejuice Batman Batman Returns Ed
Wood
just movies that
just connect me and I again I
it's about being an outsider struggling
to fit in oh Edward Scissorhands how can
I forget about Edward Scissorhands
Outsiders trying to fit in in this world
and it's interesting thinking about this
now because as an adult
you reflect upon that
from a childhood perspective of being
the kid who was bullied who was picked
on who never felt like he belonged
and now being asked this I'm kind of
like holy crap that's the reason why
I connected with these
but as I as I kind of matured throughout
the years comedies were things that I
always gravitated towards so I have my
Tim Burton Escape for the imagination
but I love comedies
favorite comedies growing up definitely
Mike Myers anything So I Married an Ax
Murderer Wayne's World Austin Powers I
don't care what anyone says all three of
them I love Goldmember I love fat
bastard
I just loved what Mike Myers did and he
was so a lot of people say he's very one
note but I just love that he had again
this imagination of creating these
different characters and it was always a
love of movies right like
Austin Powers was a love of James Bond
and all the characters but it was like
this this parody version of it and they
were so extreme every character was so
silly and over the top whether it was Dr
Eva with the one million dollars or you
know fat bastard or gold member going so
we're like cool
you know like I just really really love
that and Jim Carrey uh Jim Carrey is
another one that talk about someone who
I was obsessed with growing up Ace
Ventura the mask and Dumb and Dumber
coming out within a year span
um man my I don't know how my mom and
dad dealt with me growing up because
I just wanted to go to the movies and
live there my entire life like I just
these these movies these characters just
made me feel so alive and they were as I
as I said earlier they're just an escape
you just you just you wanted to spend
time they felt like friends
and I love things where I feel something
right whether it's laughter or heart or
a sense of like leaving this world
behind and going into another world
that's really what connected to me and
then when I moved out here the first
time I went to Chapman University
and I did a tour a couple years prior
and I saw my first Indie movies and I
I'll never forget it because it was a
back to back it went to I don't even
remember I think it was the Lemley on
Sunset five like where now it's like the
AMC Sunset 5 but it was like a Lemley
theater long time ago they wouldn't let
anyone under the age of 16 in that
theater and they showed all these great
Art House movies
and I remember this so vividly because I
saw
Lost and Delirious which was the first
movie that I have ever watched that
introduced me to lesbian characters and
I remember like seeing this love story
and I never saw anything like it before
and I fell in love with the with Piper
peribo and she was so great in that film
and it was very poetic and I just loved
it and then the following night I went
back and I saw Ghost World with you know
Torah Birch and Scarlett Johansson very
very early Scarlett Johansson
and it just opened my eyes to
independent cinema because beforehand
like I said earlier I'd been watching
all of this mainstream stuff I grew up
Mike Myers Jim Carrey Tim Burton and now
I was like these smaller movies
and they were just so incredibly
inspiring and they opened the door to so
many more so that's when I went back and
I started watching things like American
Beauty and I became such an art house
champion and you know inspired me to go
to Sundance and and do all these film
festivals because wow there's other
people telling stories that aren't just
Hollywood Studios
do you remember Jim Carreon In Living
Color oh my God Fire Marshall Bill of
course yes yes yes oh
let me show you something yeah yeah
absolutely
how often do you watch a movie
uh it changes now the pandemic really
did change things for me I used to be
the movie guy
movies only TV show what's that never
gonna watch it
pandemic completely changed that I
started seeing the movies that were
coming out during the pandemic and I
don't know if it's something with the
studios that they were trying to release
films that I would label as lesser than
they just didn't hit the way that a lot
of movies that I seen in years prior
would
so I was watching these movies at home
and I was just kind of like that was
fine that was fine that was okay oh this
one was a little bit better than that
one
and I just kept seeing on social media
all this this talk about like TV shows
and then I started going into it and I
started watching TV shows and one of the
shows that I fell in love with during
the pandemic was normal people
and normal people is with uh Daisy Edgar
Jones she's now in fresh and she has the
crawdads movie coming out and
she is just electrifying I I don't know
how else to put it but her and I believe
the guy's name is Paul Moscow I think
that's his name Pascal something like
that uh might be butchering that but
it's Paul something and this it's a very
intimate Love Story between these two
people who are just not right for one
another but they're trying to make it
work and they each have their problems
and I just remember sitting through this
and it's it's really depressing it's
really heavy
but I just remember when I finished it I
was like wow what an experience like it
made me feel
how I used to feel when I went to the
movies
and then I started watching more TV
shows whether it was like comedies like
doll face or Ted lasso that everyone's
connected with or hacks or only murders
in the building or severance
and I started having this weird pivot
where I was like
as much as I love going to the movies
is this movie that I'm going to see
gonna be as good as hacks or as good as
Severance or as good as Ted lasso and
it's weird to say this as someone who
grew up with such a fond memory of
movies and who loves movies with all his
heart
to sort of pause and kind of say
you know what I got an invite for Crimes
of the future should I go to that or
should I finish watching the dropout
and it's really really weird to have
that happen when you feel so dead set
against something for so long
but
to answer your question I know it was
like a roundabout way of getting there
I I used to go five days a week you know
when before the pandemic it was like
literally any screening that came off
Scott Menzel is there I would be going
and then it just changed because not
only with the gas prices and like
valuing of time a little bit more like I
I kind of had this realization like not
every movie needs to be seen on the big
screen
so
I'll never forget it is it's moving and
I don't mean to to crap on this movie
but like it's something that really
bothered me was they wouldn't send me a
link to see the card counter it's the
Oscar Isaac movie
and I had to do the junket for it
and I drove down to a screening room
and truthfully I didn't really like the
movie there's elements of it that I kind
of enjoyed but as a whole it just didn't
work for me
and I remember sitting in traffic
driving home and I'm like why did I have
to drive to see this
like I would have had the exact same
reaction watching this on my couch that
I would have had driving all the way
here in fact it probably would have been
a little bit better because I would have
been like Ah that's fine where now I'm
gonna lean a little bit more negative
towards it because the experience that I
had driving to the theater two people
being in the theater like like they
couldn't even fill up the screening room
it was like two people in the theater
and it's like why why
and I know people always argue the fact
that like movies need to be experienced
on the big screen
and I think it was James Gunn who said
this
but
movies have a very short life expectancy
on a big screen
they they're there for a couple of
months and then they live whether it's
on DVD on demand streaming whatever it
is nowadays
so as much as I enjoy the spectacle of
like watching like a top gun Maverick on
the big screen and that movie needs to
be experienced on the big screen
a movie like card counter where it's
just like a drama like where there's no
big set pieces there's not a lot of
action there's not a lot going on I can
enjoy that at home so my viewing habits
have pivoted from going like five days a
week to kind of going to maybe three at
most
uh and I'm more selective of what I'm
gonna drive to see because again there's
so much other content out there then I'm
like okay do I really need to see this
movie before everyone else like yes I
need to see Thor love and Thunder
but do I need to see the card counter
before everyone else or can that wait
until that plays five minutes from my
house and I'll just go randomly on a
Saturday night
I was gonna bring up the fact that I'm
in that camp too where I thought that TV
was whatever and and I've pivoted as
well yeah it's crazy yeah I I I I I feel
like I'm
I just feel like I'm being like a
traitor in a weird way to the industry
but I think a lot of people are starting
to come that that turn that corner now I
think a lot of people are just
connecting with things and they're like
wow these shows are better and I think
it's even the Studio's fault like Marvel
is turning their products
into TV shows so when you have a Wanda
Vision which to me is better than most
of these phase four movies I mean it's
way better than eternals it's way better
than doctor strange it's better than
Thor love and thunder so you have this
TV show that I think has more emotion
more depth
that
of course people are going to have the
option do I really want to go see this
or am I going to stay at home and watch
this
what's the longest you can go without
watching a movie
I would say
probably
a day or two
it's weird like
we talk about addiction all the time
entertainment is sort of addiction
whether it's
watching a trailer
or a TV show or being the first to see a
movie
there's something
that is wired up there where you just
feel this need to experience it
and the only time where I don't feel I
need to go to a movie every day
or every other day
is after I get back from a film festival
because in film festivals I go hard and
when I say I go hard I'm going from the
first screening of the day usually at
nine o'clock in the morning
until the last screening at the of the
day at 10 o'clock if you're at Sundance
it's 12 or at South by as well so I'm
literally going non-stop from nine
o'clock in the morning sometimes until
two o'clock in the morning watching
movies
and when I'm
done with a film festival
that's like the time where I can step
back for like a week and be like you
know what
I think I'm okay if I don't go
but then what happens in our industry is
that you get these nice little things
called screening invites and you're like
oh man that that's right that screen is
coming up and then even though I said to
myself I'm not gonna go for a week
oh well Batman's on Thursday I gotta go
see Batman on Thursday and that's what
happens yeah that would be difficult to
be sitting that entire time but I know
it when you when it's being like fed to
you you have no other choice oh no no
and I mean you can't Pro you can't
process everything right that's that's
the the one thing I will say about film
festivals that I think is very
interesting
in a weird way you're doing yourself and
the filmmakers and the storytellers a
little bit of a disservice because if
you see a movie that is like phenomenal
like that like knocks your socks off at
like nine o'clock in the morning and
then you have one at noon
you're going to be riding this high from
this movie that you're going to go into
the next movie
and it's going to be very very hard for
that movie to top when you just watched
and then the opposite can be said you
can watch the most horrendous movie at
nine o'clock in the morning and be like
I hope the day gets better because
you know that movie I just sat through
what a piece of crap and then you go in
the next movie and you almost have like
this well this was so much better so
it's almost like you um over hype it a
little bit and I've been I've been
I've been very guilty of this I think
like when you see stuff it's sort of
at Film Festival specifically you kind
of feel the audience reaction you kind
of feel the crowd and I've been on both
sides of that where people have been
really enjoying stuff and I've been like
in pain like Centrist like oh my God
what however I don't want to be here
anymore
or the opposite of where like I've
really enjoyed something and you can
tell like everyone around me is like not
feeling it but I do think that the more
stuff that you watch
back to back to back the harder it is to
have appropriate expectations and
reactions towards
because
what I found myself is that when I hit
in a middle ground like if I see
something really bad and then something
really good then the rest of the stuff I
kind of walk out of and go oh it's fine
it's a very weird
to explain and experience but if you go
to a film festival and you've done it
for like numerous numerous years like I
have you'll sort of understand what I'm
saying is that seeing four or five
things back to back
is not always the best way of doing it
but you feel like you almost have to
because it's like oh I don't know when
this movie is going to come out and then
there's this always this urge of like I
want to be the first person to see it I
want to be one of the first to see this
I want to be the the champion of this
movie like I I think back to CODA you
know I saw that at Sundance and that was
the movie where like I saw it I fell in
love with it and I was like this is
going to be the awards movie
and I and I literally rode that train
and everyone was like Scott you're crazy
you're crazy you're crazy and you know
in those last two months going into the
Oscars going from sag to seeing it kind
of sweep everything moving forward from
that it was it was it was great to see
yeah there's like an Afterglow with a
great film where you need time to like
process you you come out of the theater
it's dark but you're still in that world
and you're still in those characters and
it is difficult then to go to another
equally great one or whatever it loses
something because that's the beauty of
loving a film is you're lost in it for
weeks sometimes almost a lifetime if
it's really that powerful yeah I think
what the problem is too is that and I I
said this online and I've I've often
gotten criticism from it
is that
I don't like having an instant reaction
to things
but the way that we as film critics are
and what has kind of been programmed
into our brains is that we want to react
to something as soon as we see it it's
it's what I keep saying about being the
first you want to get into that first
screening you want to be the first to
see the Batman you want to be the first
to see top gun Maverick right there's
something special about being part of
that initial Buzz to kind of be like I
saw this before other people and it's
not anything about ego it's just this
kind of this this feeling of like wow I
was important enough or this studio
looked at me and trust my opinion well
enough that they would include me in
those first batch of reviews of those
first batch of reactions
so I often come out of a movie and
almost subconsciously
first thing I do pull out my phone
and I just start taping reactions I mean
even stuff that's out
like it's just like okay this movie's
been out but I still feel like I have to
chime in on it like when we were at
um a couple of days ago we went to see
minions and I didn't go to this press
screening for that because it was a busy
week and I wanted to see it at a regular
theater and it was funny because I'm
singing with everyone else and yet as
soon as it's done pull out my phone
reaction it's like there's no need like
all the reviews are out but it's just
like this knee-jerk thing that we all do
because we've become programmed that you
want to be part of that buzz you want to
be part of that experience and that's
what social media does I mean in a lot
of ways it's kind of you know again
another controversial tub subject is
it has taken away from in-depth reviews
I used to be the type of person who
would spend
five hours writing a review and I mean
my wife used to laugh at me all the time
she's like
what do you write a novel over there
like you're talking like 1 500 2 000
words every review I I wrote I would go
into like what worked what did and how
it made me feel yada yada yada and it's
so weird because
you put out a tweet and it's like
instant gratification right it's just
like oh oh man he really liked that
that's like oh look look at it look at
all the retwees what are all the likes
and then you post the review like a week
later and you like literally poured five
hours of your time into it it's like 10
retweets 10 likes
and after a while it almost becomes
discouraging you're like why am I going
to spend all this time
pouring my heart and soul sitting down
when I could just have a conversation on
a podcast or on a Twitter spaces
for 15 minutes talk about how I feel and
more people are going to pay attention
to to it that way or even better just
write five tweets and put them in in a
in a thread and there you go and more
people are going to read that and pay
attention to it than anything that I
write in long form
what about when something's embargoed
how do you how do you stop yourself
oh that's
that's really difficult especially when
again it's it's the extremes of
everything right if it's a movie that
you walk out of and you're like it's
fine or you don't really have a reaction
to those are the those are the hardest
ones to review the hardest movies to
talk about
and the ones that have no impact on the
in embargoes because you're just kind of
like all right don't really have much to
say about that anyway but it's when you
see something that's so good or so bad
and I I can tell you this
I have no problem admitting this
I
will tell you that Studios
will
absolutely kill you if you
slander a movie that they have really
really high praise for they're hoping if
they have a really strong box office and
you come out and rip it to shreds when
the Embargo lifts
without going into details I have been
kicked off lists many of times for years
at a time because I said so and so movie
was not good and
it's not just the studios it's it's the
producers it's the directors it's the
Stars they're like did you see what this
person said about our thing and again
social media the lack of control and
everyone's looking for the next click
bait headline
that I have had some tweets of like
something that I felt really strongly
about like in terms of negative
be the headlines of major Publications
as like this movie is the most
disappointing movie that I have seen all
year
and when that gets out and Studios see
that and Talon sees that
not a good not a good look and it's been
really difficult because I always pride
myself on being very very honest
but then sometimes I've also realized
that I'm too honest and I'm kind of kind
of brutally honest to a fault that I've
been sort of trying to find the good
with the bad so I'll try to kind of say
this this and this are pretty good but
this was really bad so it kind of like
Waters down in a little bit so it
doesn't come off as like so harsh and
again
I think that's what any good critic
should do is that they should be able to
look at something and kind of say okay
this movie's really not that good but
there's got to be something good about
it so now I've been more
I don't know take a little bit more time
to process something if I if I have a
immediate like knee-jerk reaction to it
we'll have like negativity that I I want
to process it a little bit and kind of
say okay is there anything about this
that I liked
and kind of make that a little known as
well
and then I'll hammer in on the negative
but I think it's it's really hard
nowadays because this this
this this area that we live in with
criticism
it's so vast because before
it was like you worked for a trade or
you worked for a newspaper or TV Outlet
right those were like the three things
and now and I mean this is not new but
like over the past 15 years it's like
you can be a YouTube reviewer you can be
you can have your own blog you can be on
Tick Tock you can be on Instagram you
can be all over you could just do
Twitter you could do letterbox so like
all these voices are kind of coming
together and the studios and they really
do pick people
and they it's it's all about
relationships and I I pride myself on
trying to have a good relationship with
as many people as possible but I always
promised myself that I have to be honest
I if I don't like something
I have to I have to be able to say that
I don't like something I get their their
fear of like maybe not being the first
person out of the gate to kind of rip
something to shreds but to me something
that's being lost nowadays is like this
fear of like losing your access
because you're honest
and I think that's a good point and and
I think it's good to be respected and
not have sort of a used car salesman
Vibe too which I know is prevalent
sometimes in Hollywood but at the same
time I think we've all read reviews
where whoever it is just went for the
jugular on this person and you don't
know did they know them in college like
had is there was there a prior beef and
they just they just attack them on so
many levels so I think there's like this
middle ground but yeah I respect that
that you want to be be honest about the
review and not uh sugar coat it or just
that that's turkey because you want to
be invited back yeah I mean the problem
with criticism nowadays is that
if you're not a voice that agrees with
the masses and and again what are the
masses nowadays right because we live in
our own like bubbles like the industry
film Twitter
Instagram Twitter whatever the heck it
is
all of these things they're very
specific to a very small audience
and you kind of get like obsessed with
it right like and people are on the
internet as we all know are very mean
especially if you voice something that's
different
so I mean I'll give you an example dear
Evan Hansen I like dear Evan Hansen I
like the Broadway musical I like the
movie is it a great movie
no it's it's good
but I'll tell you as one of the voices
to kind of stand up for that movie
the amount of hate you get when you just
kind of disagree with everyone like oh
this has terrible messaging how can you
like something like this and you try to
explain yourself like look at it from
this perspective and like no no no you
don't get it like that's wrong you can't
look at it from that perspective it's
very very difficult to kind of defend
yourself because you're not having a
conversation with with a person you're
having a conversation online with people
who are too afraid to talk to you to
your face
and that's what's also weird about film
criticism is that
a lot of these filmmakers
and actors have now become known to who
I am as a person because I run a critics
organization and because I run a critics
organization I also have to pause a
little bit about my reactions to things
because how does this affect other
members within our organization
so if I don't like something like power
of the dog
how is Netflix going to react when that
movie gets nominated
and we do an award show and we need
those people there
so it kind of has this weird thing that
I start thinking about is like is is
that the reason why most people from
Power the dog didn't come to the award
show because they knew that the person
at the top of the
this organization didn't care for the
movie and then you just kind of have
this weird pause
and I think that that that kind of
trickles down into every aspect of of
filmmaking now is that we see this with
fans right like Sonic right the backlash
of the character design everyone like
backlashed against it and then they
redid the character design granted for
the greater good for that one but Star
Wars Marvel DC it's like there's so much
outpouring of like criticism and Hate
that you almost struggle to kind of like
know where your voice is anymore
because
you want to support these things and you
I love to Champion creativity and I
always agree with the statement of
artists objective
and I think so many people forget about
it it's like how can you not like this
this movie and it's like just didn't
resonate with me it didn't I didn't like
the characters I didn't like their
Direction I didn't like the story I
didn't like the way it was filmed
there's so many different things that
some person that one person could see
and another person will see something
different and you just kind of have to
learn to live with it so I never I never
take any offense when people really
disagree with me my only thing is when
people start name-calling and like
really start playing you down as like
the worst critic ever because you didn't
like something it's like no it's just
like I didn't see what you saw sorry
how do you judge a movie
this is a great question because I think
everyone judges a movie differently
a lot of people will judge a movie based
on
its visual Style
it's score it's production value for me
it's kind of has to be the complete
package
and I think it starts
with characters
and story are key you can have the most
beautiful looking film in the world
but if I watch a movie and the story
doesn't connect with me and I don't care
about any of the characters it doesn't
matter how good the score is doesn't
matter how good the costumes are
doesn't matter how great the
cinematography is
the story sucks the movie sucks
and I think that's something that I
struggle with a lot nowadays
when it comes to films because if you've
noticed there's become this very bad
pattern in the industry
where everyone has said visually
stunning everything's visually stunning
cinematic
no matter what it is
and you're like you watch these movies
and it's like what's with these
characters like why are they
underdeveloped why are they like
doing these like what's what's what's
the reasoning behind their actions
and that's what I focus on so like for
me characters and story are key to any
movie and it doesn't matter to me it
doesn't matter if a movie doesn't have
like the most
I don't know
spectacle of Direction
but if you have a story that connects
with viewers
that will Elevate the movie almost in
every way sure you can say like oh is
someone so direct at this movie don't
you think it would have been a little
bit better sure
but I still think it comes down to those
two key elements of you have to have
characters that are going to resonate
with an audience and you have to have a
story that's going to connect with an
audience and that's all it is to it
because nowadays visual movies are dime
a dozen every Marvel movie is a visually
stunning movie every DC movie is a
visually stunning movie every Star Wars
movie every animation all of that stuff
visually stunning it's what goes into
the meat and potatoes of like those
characters and the story that's being
told that makes it worthy of your time
or not okay Elvis visually stunning but
excellent characters yes would you agree
yes okay yes yes and I I have to say
with Elvis
it's a balancing of tone in a weird way
too because
I know a lot of people are criticizing
Tom hanks's character in that movie oh I
didn't know that yes a lot of people are
criticizing it because it's kind of very
over the top it's almost like almost
like a doctor evil type villain like I'm
so menacing and the way that baz luhrman
shoots certain scenes with him it's kind
of almost like he's going like oh yeah
oh yes Elvis is mine right so I I
watched some of this and I'm kind of
like okay like this is a little over the
top here but when you go into like a
rock star life
they hit upon so much in this two and a
half hour run time of you know his
stuff down in in Memphis and his impact
and his drug addiction his women abuse
his his claim to fame of like being
inspired by the music in the black
community there's so much that they're
trying to cram in here that in a weird
way I almost found it refreshing that
Tom Hanks was in this movie being like
this character that was like over the
top because it took away from how
serious the rest of the movie was
and I think you have Austin Butler
literally putting in a performance of a
lifetime in this movie like I just
it's been such a long time I was
thinking about this I think it was like
Ray Charles with Rey was the last time
that I seen an actor
totally like just become another person
and and this is not like Prosthetics
like you know Gary Oldman and Darkest
Hour like his great performance don't
get me wrong but it's the Prosthetics
right you you forget it's him because of
all this this makeup and hair with this
it's just like the voice it's it's the
commitment just like it was with Jamie
Foxx
and you watch this movie and you just
again you fall in love with the
characters right it's Austin Butler
becomes Elvis and the movie's about
Elvis and you fall in love with that
character and you like the journey and
it's like critics are like ah it's
overlooking certain things in his life
like these biopics that we all know
nowadays you have to have rights to tell
this story and there's going to be very
few people who are going to let you
on their on that person they're not
gonna say oh yeah you know what
show how terrible he was when like
family members were still alive they're
not going to do that just like we saw
with Bohemian Rhapsody the band didn't
want to go through all the dark stuff in
there they they touched upon it just
like they do in Elvis but it it does
glance over things but the bottom line
is you still have a character and you're
telling a story about Fame and Fortune
and like this love of of music right and
a love of like performing and what it is
to feel the crowd and wanting to travel
around the world and you know sadly
Elvis never got to do that he only got
to do it within the states and because
of stories that we got to hear in this
movie but
it was great because you connected with
the character and you understood it's
it's a dreamer movie right Elvis was a
dreamer and those are the movies that I
think for me are the ones that I
resonate with the most because those are
the ones that are kind of universal in
their messaging which is why when you
see a movie like Elvis people will clap
at the end of it when you go see it with
a regular audience because it gives them
this this level of Hope but at the same
time elf is not a happy movie like at
the end of it it's kind of sad
but it gives you that that full meal you
get that's that like the climb effect to
fame
the the life of Fame the bad side of
Fame and then like trying to find your
voice within there and then the tragedy
of what it is and so I think it's a
really
well-structured movie as a whole again
not perfect
but very few movies are right and in
going into the movie it was moving very
fast and I thought oh no this is going
to be one of these rushed biopics yeah
visually stunning as it was but but it
something about it hooked me in and I
didn't feel like it was rushed but in
the beginning I wasn't sure if that's
where we were going I think that's
because it's baz learning right I mean
baz luhrmann as a filmmaker
very hit or miss and as much as again
you can have visual style and you can
never take that away from baslerman
bazlerman has a very specific look and
feel to all his movies the way he
incorporates modern music with old
school music he does it's his signature
Style
and what I was worried about with Elvis
was I thought like Great Gatsby where it
overtook the movie right like it was so
much of like modern music in there and
it was so over stylized
that you just you kind of forgot like
this is a great piece of literature with
Great Gatsby and that's all like lost in
the spectacle
but with Elvis I think it's weird
because I think I saw an interview with
him that he wasn't like the biggest
Elvis fan in the world right like he
wasn't like you would think when you're
doing a biopic you would pick someone
who's like obsessed and I think he he
admitted that he really wasn't obsessed
he knew of him and he was kind of
fascinated with him but he wasn't like
oh my God I have to do this like this is
not like his dream project
but like he somehow made it into his his
dream project and I think
that's kind of captured in Austin Butler
right it's like I love movies where they
find an actor who has really not been
taken seriously before
and you put him in this world and you
create this story around him
and everyone just like people who hate
Elvis
can say at the very least that Austin
Butler didn't give at least a good
performance
some people might be like me where
they're extreme and go like this is one
of the best performances that I've seen
in like 10 years
but most people would say that Elise is
a good performance
people are mixed on the movie but the
performance so I think baslerman really
does with this one I think he understood
that it was more about the story and
more about the character
than it was about the visual he wanted
to create his sense of style he had to
put it in there which is why if you
watch the first half of that movie it's
much more of a traditional baslerman
movie with everything he does thrown at
you but the second half of it is way
more of just kind of like okay this is
the story this is where like things
where the hits the fan things are
going to get real here and we're going
to focus on that and it really is
kind of uneven to be truthful but I
think that second half is so strong that
it actually makes up for the first half
right and I was worried about that would
the would the payoff in the end Wane
because everything was up front and
would you say that's almost a smart
thing for a filmmaker not to be too
obsessed with someone's life story
because it's going to be biased if they
go in sort of neutral
yeah I mean I mean this ties into so
many different things
I think being a fan of someone
is very difficult now because again
going back to the internet
it's almost like oh you're the go-to so
this is no surprise to anyone who knows
me I'm a big Kristen Stewart fan and I'm
a big Kristen Stewart supporter and I
have been since speak when it premiered
at Sundance
but
I can admit that not every movie she
does
or has been a part of is good
sometimes she's not good in the movie
sometimes the movie's not good sometimes
she's the best part of the movie
sometimes the movie's great and
everything's great
as a filmmaker I agree I think it's it's
really hard because if you really
idolize someone
it can go either one or two ways
it can go so extreme where you're just
like the ultimate Fanboy fan girl and
you're just like making this love letter
that is just like
oh my God I idolize this person I love
them so much
and then if you don't you have on the
other end of that if you have someone
who doesn't know anything about the
person you run the risk of kind of not
being accurate and not feeling the heart
because biopics in a weird way
need that middle ground you have to love
someone in in into on a certain extent
but you also
have to realize that they're flawed and
that they're not perfect and that they
have dark sides
and that's I think what really stood out
to me about this and it even
Rocket Man right Rocket Man
Elton John was so involved with it right
but Elton John's the type of celebrity
who's not afraid of what people think
because he hosts Oscar he's like the one
of the most beloved people in the
industry you know like so he's not
really afraid to show his Dark Side of
Things
but
is Queen afraid of showing their Dark
Side probably because they're still
touring and they're still making money
Freddy's not here anymore but they're
still part of it so they don't want
anyone to kind of see something and kind
of view it and go like oh I don't know
about those guys anymore right and
that's where I think you
you have this really fine line of
everything right you have
how much do family members have this
involvement in this movie are they are
they controlling it too much that it's
not accurate enough
and then do you have a filmmaker who's
capable of telling the story
that it doesn't feel like a documentary
you know like where it's actually going
to be to mean documentaries
are so one-sided majority of them right
you're watching a documentary and you're
kind of like okay this is like set out
to be like tell me like Michael Moore
he hates Trump I know you hate Trump you
know like no no so like you're not a
surprise you're watching this movie
you're watching this documentary and
you're not surprised no one who likes
Trump's gonna watch this movie so like
who are you making this movie for but
when you go to biopics too I think that
it has that problem too because you want
to learn something
when you watch a biopic
that you don't
set you don't always need the the clean
and shiny version of it you want some
Darkness but there's a there's a balance
and I I don't know I feel like biopics
are always getting such like mixed
reactions from critics and rightfully so
because they either go too heavy or not
heavy enough
and there's like there's there's no in
between with all them and one of my
favorite movies of recent years and I
and I enjoyed the fact that it was more
of the spectacle
is the greatest Showman because the
greatest showman is not trying to be
this biopic right they literally made up
characters in the movie it was just
supposed to be a musical that's fun and
entertaining and then when I'm reading
critics
they didn't show the dark side of his
life I'm like
at no point did this movie say that it
was going to be this hard hitting tale
about this it was supposed to be a
lighthearted thing so I understand why
some people watch Elvis and they
criticize how they grow you know glossed
over things and how they watched
Bohemian Rhapsody but at the end of the
day these movies are appealing to the
masses the what what we as film critics
sometimes want is not what the studio
wants nor what audiences want that's a
good point because in the theater was a
couple that could not stay off their
phone they were online shopping but they
eventually put it away so obviously it
got their attention enough from close to
the beginning and then there was another
family that was at one point standing up
just talking but but we were able to
finish the movie as a group so very
diverse group that was in there but
somehow their attention as much as they
kind of wanted to squirm and do things
was kept and and I agree on on showing
the different sides is difficult in the
film one film that I'm kind of a broken
record on is this John DeLorean movie
which was a movie within a movie so it
was several independent filmmakers who
were hoping to make a documentary on
them and it was a narrative it was his
family members and they all came
together to kind of give different sides
of the story of how it it transpired and
I thought that was fascinating I hadn't
seen too many like that yeah so um and
Alec Baldwin plays uh John DeLorean and
he's as himself contemplating what what
would John have done in this scene and
things so that was seemed like it was
more of an all-around representation but
I get it we only want to see sort of one
version of the person yeah I mean and
it's all based on who you talk to right
so the biggest issue with biopics now
right is that you have the movie that
the studio wants you have the movie that
the director wants yeah the movie that
the audience wants you have the movie
that the critics want
and it's very very rare that all four of
those people are going to agree
and I think that's a huge problem which
is why I think
biopics always get such a mixed reaction
is because it leans in one like right
like Rocket Man was leaning into the
dark side and because of Elton John it
did really well
but it didn't do as well as a Bohemian
Rhapsody
because that leaned into more of the
spectacle
and more of the music you have 30
minutes at the end where you have that
um what is that Aid I forgot the name of
it but they have the the AIDS the Live
Aid scene at the end and they're just
performing I mean that is still probably
one of the best scenes
in a movie in the last decade because
it's just it's just it's it's musical
spectacle it's Queen Why We Love Queen
and Rocket Man even though they kind of
had like almost like a Broadway approach
to it of like here's a musical number
we're gonna bust into a musical song
here and they look gonna go through a
set and blah blah blah blah it's great
but people really love those moments
where it's just like 30 minutes of like
this is what I want this is what I want
and again critics not so much audiences
yes same with musicals people want they
want to feel like they're watching a
stage Musical on the big screen and
sometimes those numbers are not big
enough they feel very small
so yeah it's it's really trying I don't
I don't envy people who are doing these
these jobs anymore because you're
appealing to so many different people
and it's really difficult now because of
what we talked about earlier social
media everyone has a voice
and everyone has something to say so one
person might love another person hates
and it depends on who picks that up and
who runs it as a headline as to whether
or not that movie will will sink or
float
what makes comic book movies great
another question that depends on who you
ask
to me
my favorite comic book movies are the
ones that Embrace being a comic book
we've seen a really big pivot in this
over the last couple of years I think
Noland was the one who kind of changed
the game with this with
Batman Begins
because we then approached
superhero movies as being grounded in
the real world
and as much as I enjoyed Nolan's views
on that and his style and what he's done
with the characters
he's almost set up this this stage for
many comic book movies to fail
because we want them almost to be
grounded in reality now
and again going back to
my childhood and growing up as a kid of
the 80s
I grew up with Adam West Batman which is
like so silly and over the top
and then you had of course Christopher
Reeves with Superman
Tim burn with Batman and Batman Returns
and they all had this very much like
different world
I was escaping to a different world
and then Nolan came in and he was like
no it could be grounded in reality and
then we've seen this even with Joker
we've seen it with the Matt Reeves
Batman
where it's very grounded
and then on the other end of the
spectrum you've got kind of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
that they've been trying to tie in real
world issues into this comic book space
but I I know I sound like I'm beating a
dead horse here but it all comes back
down to story
and characters
if a character is well developed whether
it's a comic book movie
or any type of movie you're going to
find an audience you're going to connect
people are going to connect right people
like Tony Stark
because he's a cool character but he's
also a well-developed character Robert
Downey Jr really made that character his
own and while a lot of people say that a
lot of Tony Stark is just Robert Downey
Jr
that's the way the character was written
it was written for him
so you're just you may be just watching
him
but you've grown to like him and the
stories help Elevate him
and that's what's great about it so to
me
you you can have all these characters
it's what you do with their progression
how the movie starts where it goes in
the middle and How It Ends is whether
it's going to be a good comic book movie
or not is it going to leave you wanting
more are you going to want to see more
of this character because we all know
and unfortunately nowadays
one movie is Never Enough one movie is
never enough so as much as I like Joker
and I was hoping that joker was going to
be a one-off
there's a joker two coming and it's
gonna be a musical and all these people
are gonna be in it
yeah I'm curious to see it don't get me
wrong but the reason why people like
that movie and why people connected with
that movie is that it again they liked
what
Joaquin Phoenix brought to the table
they like that character they liked the
way that it was written what what he was
able to do with that material so
everything else sure the visual style
everyone loved about it you know
everyone referencing Oh Martin scorses
you look and all this stuff
but if you take Joaquin Phoenix out of
that
does the movie like what would that
movie be with another actor and that's
that's what you really you really got to
focus on is that character and who's I
guess also I should say whose cast is
that character
right because do those people
become the character that you want them
to be you get lost in Joaquin Phoenix as
Joker right we get that we like that
Iron Man we know it's Robert Downey Jr
in a lot of these movies with so many
characters nowadays
eternals I I don't mean to keep crapping
on this movie but like to me you have
too many actors
no character develop development no
story like where is this going I have no
idea I walked away from that movie If I
never seen those characters again I'd be
completely fine
but you you want to spend more time with
characters and character development is
so important especially in superhero
movies because you know that they're
going to keep making them
so like if if an actor is bad in a role
and the story doesn't work
it again doesn't matter the production
value doesn't matter the costumes
doesn't matter the hair and makeup
it's it's not going to win people over
and that's what you're seeing right now
I think with the phases this last phase
of Marvel is that you're seeing so many
things get thrown at you
you're seeing you're seeing Sam raimi's
fingerprints all over doctor strange but
yet people are complaining like oh did
this person not watch Wanda Vision
because Elizabeth Olsen is weird in this
movie she doesn't seem to like realize
what happened in one division
and what is Benedict Cumberbatch doing
here he was so different in this one
compared to how he was in the other
movies and you watch in a weird way even
Thor right it's like okay like he's he's
out of shape and now like all of a
sudden like he's back in shape and like
a montage
I don't know they're losing the the
writing it's becoming
style over substance is what I've what
I've been seeing with Marvel phase four
is style over substance there's so much
style and they're trying to combine
these two ideas like there's a taika
with TT movie here and then there's the
Marvel movie here there's a Sam Raimi
movie here and then there's the Marvel
movie here and you you really need to
believe in your director and your cast
and your screenwriters to tell the story
they want us to tell I mean this kind of
takes me back to
you know Zack Snyder right I mean
Zack Snyder's Justice League that came
out on HBO Max after fan support for
like
seems like almost a decade but it was
only like five years but the outpouring
of support was because everyone who knew
Zack Snyder knew that that movie that
they put in theaters wasn't his vision
and they weren't happy about it and
that's why there was so much of a fight
for it because
these are beloved characters that people
know that literally
decades upon Decades of comic books were
written about and yes he didn't follow
the formula that probably Warner
Brothers wanted
but he wanted to tell his vision and
they they mess with his vision
and that's the thing about his movies
that I respect him about
you can watch Man of Steel
you can watch Batman v Superman you can
watch
just new Justice League the complete
four-hour cut of it
and you can hate it it's completely fine
but at least you know it's the movie
that he wanted to make I think it's
really bad for comic book movies
nowadays when you feel like a director
is being dictated what they're doing
they're not they don't have creative
control they get partial creative
control and then it's almost like
someone steps in it's like no no no
you gotta do this this
as long as you do this this
is going and it just becomes a tonal
mess and I I it's weird and I'm saying
this because
Marvel was always the leg up on DC for
like a long time there because they had
a formula and I'm not saying that movies
every movie needs a formula
but right now it's just like it's so
inconsistent I I walk out of a movie and
I just kind of go oh okay like I'm like
this this was awesome this was terrible
like I really don't know like
the last like two or three Marvel movies
were like five out of tens for me
because I'm like I like things so much
about these but I hate so much about
these
so yeah it's it's I think it's changed
so much over the years you know because
again you go into the the time of the
80s and 90s where it was like camping
and it really sort of like really
embraced what a comic book movie was and
it wasn't worried about the reality and
now we're kind of with the spectacle
we're with the substance and I think
it's really you know and this is no no
criticism because I think Nolan was
great Christopher Nolan did such a great
job of telling in such a grounded story
that you really felt like this could
happen anywhere but in a weird way it
almost like no one knew how to react to
it because you only have one Christopher
Nolan that's the thing with him as a
filmmaker he has a very unique vision
so he can tell a story and I think a lot
of people try to replicate that even
with the spectacle and he can't match it
because for him what always came first
was yes it's a big big scale movie but
he always cared about the story he
always cared about the characters and he
picked the right actors to play those
characters
again even a smaller comic book movie uh
American Splendor yes so Paul Giamatti
as Harvey pankar or oh my God yeah I
mean he he from when you saw a little
bit you heard some of his voice and
different things and and you can go back
to Old Letterman uh interviews and and
you felt like that was him he really
like embodied this guy this this guy
that was in this tough spot that felt
trapped in his life and and felt like he
wasn't going to be able to do anything
but be this file clerk yeah that's a
great movie by the way that was that was
another one that I saw very early on uh
and I I just love that that film I mean
Paul Giamatti speaking of comic book
movies remember when he was in that
Spider-Man movie and so underused and
never used again yeah it was very
bizarre but yeah Paul Giamatti is still
one of the greatest actors working today
sure so it sounds like for lack of a
better term if an actor's actor is is
the main character is this superhero or
whatever anti-hero whatever then then it
works but if it's too surface of a
performance it's not gonna yeah I mean
that's that's that really is a great
point and a great way of looking at
things it's like does the actor fit the
role
like
do they Encompass what this character is
you know and that's why I mean there's
always been this debate about Batman
right but like to me Michael Keaton will
always be the best Batman because I
literally just felt like he brought
himself to the performance just like you
can never tell me that Robert Downey Jr
wasn't like the perfect Iron Man there's
just certain actors that become these
characters and I know that they have
these different versions of them the
only one that's really weird that like
every actor who's kind of Taken on
besides Jared Leto
um is Joker
like Joker for some reason whoever takes
on that character brings something
unique to it
you know I mean even going back to Cesar
Romano right from like I mean the
cheesiness and the over top clowniness
of that
he was great as that character then you
got Jack Nicholson in the role you got
Heath Ledger and I'm gonna skip over
Carolina and go right to Joaquin Phoenix
like every one of those were like so
uniquely different and I think with
Batman right it's it's kind of like the
mystery of like it but like
only
Michael Keaton was able to balance the
Bruce Wayne and the Batman
where like you watch Robert Pence and
his Batman and he's he's good at Batman
Bruce Wayne yeah you know and I we don't
have to talk about George Clooney he's
not when we could just go and get our
glance over you know Val Kilmer was
probably you know again that was more
again coming back to the script like
that was a not a great script that he
had to work with
but you know he tried and then Christian
Bale I feel like again great Bruce Wayne
the Batman he never got the voice down
Christian Bale as great of an actor as
he is I just felt like he never got that
that voice down and which is why he's
always being made fun of like I'm Batman
you know like everyone always like jokes
about that because he just he wasn't
able to fully get it so that's why I
always say that Michael Keaton is is Top
Dog for Batman how about Margot Kidder
Lois Lane
she embodied Lois Lane yeah yeah I think
so I mean and that's the the big
disconnect right with a lot of people
had with
um oh my God Amy Adams with Lois Lane
right like
she didn't really become the character
she didn't really get enough depth
and enough story she just kind of like
was underdeveloped a character that is
so iconic and so well known and loved
and how many Superman TV shows have
there been and like all this thing
Superman and low is Lois and Clark like
all this stuff there's been all these
stories and
that that character really deserves to
have someone really do them Justice on
the big screen because I don't know
you're right since going back to the
original Superman I don't know if anyone
is has ever played that character well
that's interesting because everything
Amy Adams does otherwise I haven't seen
that performance so I can't speak to it
but I love her and everything yeah else
that she does so I don't know I'll have
to actually watch it and see yeah yeah
it's not that she's mad in it it's just
that it's a character that's not written
well I mean it's it's almost like
going into the superhero conversation
it's it's almost like Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman 1984.
Wonder Woman and Zack Snyder's Justice
League okay so Wonder Woman as a movie
up until the last Act is is badass like
I don't know I mean Gal Gadot and that
performance is just so great she
embodies the role she becomes that
character and she inspired so many you
know young girls I mean I just remember
that press day coming out and like how
many people you know little girls and
women were like so empowered by her
performance
and then you you see her in Zack
Snyder's Justice League and she's she's
again she's she's that way
and then I don't know what happened in
1984 like I'm not someone who hates that
movie I know a lot of people hate that
movie
but she's like she's there and the rest
of the movie's failing her she's like
doing her her best to make this stuff
work but she's got Pedro Pascal like
Hamming it up up to 30 like a 90. I
don't know what he's doing in that movie
there's like this weird rock story line
and then you know let alone when the
critics got all got all over it with
this like subjective rape or some stuff
with rape going on in the movie which
like I didn't even like bother paying
attention to but like she did she became
you know because of that you know and I
credit Zack Snyder for that because Zack
Snyder took the chance Patty you know
Patty Jenkins put her in the the first
movie that really got her shine
but Zack Snyder hired her he's the one
who saw the potential
and and and made her the character and
then Patty Jenkins pushed her to the
next level and then in a weird way kind
of pushed threw it down the stairs in
the next movie so uh I I don't know and
again I don't hate 1984. I just think
it's a missed opportunity but I I felt
so I was thinking about that movie and I
feel so bad for for Gago though because
she's sitting there and she's trying so
hard at the end of that movie and she's
really pouring her heart and soul into
that performance and she's really great
in it but it's just like that script
that script it's not good it's not good
wishing you more excited to see nope or
Black Adam
uh nope just because
it's an original idea
I love Dwayne Johnson so like I'm super
pumped about it
but nope original concept will win all
the time for me
again it ties back to
go into an independent movie theater at
such a late age and seeing movies like
Lost and Delirious and Ghost World
Original Stories just have have a
special place in my heart and as much as
I love the spectacle
if you kind of put them side by side and
say do you want to watch something
that's original or do you want to see
something that's connected to a known
franchise
nine times out of ten I'm gonna pick the
original concept
and with Jordan peel
I mean how can you not love him as a
filmmaker he's he's he's bold he's
ambitious
and get out I I remember seeing get out
at Sundance they did a midnight
screening it was a surprise screening
and I
watched that with a small crowd they had
at the library the library is one of the
smaller venues at Sundance it only holds
about like three to four hundred people
and at two o'clock in the morning
because it's a midnight screening two
o'clock in the morning to hear that
audience just erupt with Applause and
connect and see the reactions that night
and the next morning
and then like again going back to our
earlier conversation about being able to
experience things being the first to
experience things you feel like you saw
something special right and and seeing
Jordan peel his directorial debut seeing
him do something that you had no
expectations that he had in him like who
expected the guy who was on key and peel
to make a horror movie that had so much
depth and like made so many white people
uncomfortable right I mean like it was
it was so much it was so funny reading
a lot of my white colleagues reviews of
that movie like everyone was like who
really understood like it was like he
really made me feel uncomfortable and
like everyone trying to under act like
they understood Black Culture at that
point it was it was so hilarious and
then you know Jordan Peele took the
second movie
um oh my God what was the second movie
us to uh South by Southwest
and I and I remember seeing that in the
first two acts of that movie worked
really well and I was really
disappointed with the last act I I
didn't think that movie really was on
the same level as get out
but this looks like it's in a totally
different direction
I have no idea what this is it like
looks like it's a Sci-Fi comedy
and every trailer like
it has elements to it where I'm kind of
like this is either going to be like a
complete train wreck or this is going to
be like one of the best movies of the
year and I I really can't decide because
there's just things in the trailer that
you're watching this and you're like
what's happening there's cows up here
flying
okay like is this twister and then
you're like sitting there and then you
have like kind of like the social
commentary down the on the ground there
and I'm like this looks brilliant so it
Universal definitely knows what they're
doing with him and I'm so glad that they
signed on to to the the Jordan peel
roller coaster ride because I don't know
if audiences are quite
ex know what they're expecting with this
one I don't think people I don't think
any of us know so I'm very curious to
see it so of nope or Black Adam which do
you think will be the bigger hit for
just from the little that you've seen
it's hard to say because you have
short and peel has such a name behind
him because those two movies were such
massive hits
that that I almost want to say that
that's going to be bigger
but there's the uncertainty there right
the thing about comic book movies
is that you already have a built-in
audience
that are going to see it and Dwayne
Johnson is arguably
the biggest movie star in the world
and like he sells movies he's one of the
he's like Tom Cruise right he sells
movies people know who Dwayne Johnson is
they go to movies because
Dwayne Johnson's in it just like people
go to Tom Cruise movies because Tom
Cruise is in it
Top Gun was a success not because it was
a Top Gun movie but because it was a Tom
Cruise movie
so I mean it's a good movie regardless
but I'm just saying like that's the
reason why butts went in seats because
of Tom Cruise so it's really hard
because I do feel
it depends on the reaction of nope
from critics and audiences to dictate
whether that's going to be the big movie
or Black Adam so right now
I'm gonna say Black Adam just because
it's the safer because it has a two for
two it has the Super the superhero
element
and it has Dwayne Johnson where I feel
like Jordan peel has the name but it
also has that original idea that can go
either way
what are your five most anticipated
movies for 2022
we're halfway through
[Music]
we are halfway through
um
well it's not Avatar
there is
a Christmas musical comedy coming out
that everyone's watching this is like
what
with Ryan Reynolds and Will Ferrell
coming out
that I think is going to be a ton of fun
I I I have nothing to basis off of no
trailer just that it's a musical comedy
set around Christmas and I have a very
big soft spot for Ryan Reynolds so I'm
definitely very very excited about that
I'm going to say
don't worry darling Olivia Wilde's
newest movie
she she blew me away with book smart
I've always been a fan of her as an
actress I know people are kind of
lukewarmer lukewarm on her as an actress
I've always been a fan and especially
when again going back to the Indie
movies when she started doing like a lot
of Indie rolls I felt like she was just
superb in them
so I'm very curious this looks like such
a big scale film like book smart felt
like a small Indie comedy like it was
like a coming of an age
Indie comedy but this feels like it's a
massive scale and I mean the cast with
you know Florence Pew and and Chris Pine
it feels like it's big so I'm really
looking forward to that one
I'm trying to think what else oh Shazam
the the second Shazam
David David F Sandberg such a big fan of
him uh going back to lights out I love
the first shazam movie talk about it
talk about just a fun fun movie a reason
people go to the movies just to have a
good time get a little bit of a
spectacle get a little bit of a comedy
Zachary Levi in that just just just
perfect again perfect casting we're
talking about a superhero casting
earlier
somebody who really loves superheroes
and wanted to be one and then he got to
cast as one Perfection there were
casting so that's three
um
I'm really excited about Amsterdam I I
know that
people are a little bit hesitant on that
because of the director
but I I think that's a one of those
Ensemble pieces that is going to have a
lot of great performances in it and is
going to have a really good story
and then I guess I I mean how could I
not say the Martin Scorsese movie right
the killers of the flower moon like it's
Scorsese and Leonardo DiCaprio that has
worked in the past so I'm pretty sure
it's going to work again and I'm gonna
I'm gonna sneak another one in I have to
say Babylon I can't believe I forgot
about Babylon Damien chazelle's latest
uh with Margot Robbie cannot wait I saw
saw a small teaser Ford at uh cinemacon
totally up my alley totally excited for
it how would you rate the movies of 2022
to previous years
oh that's
truthfully
um I don't know if the industry has
fully recovered since 2020.
um there's definitely been some bright
spots
this year and there there has been some
real signs of of Hope at the at the
movie theater
but
Blockbusters this year so far
outside of top gun Maverick
I'm not really feeling them I'm really
not it's I as much as I like Batman
I felt like it was 30 minutes too long
again the ground in reality there's like
two movies there like there's literally
like one and a half movies there's
literally like a cutting cutting point
in Batman where it's kind of like okay
this movie could have ended here and the
sequel could have started here but it
keeps going and then you kind of get
like half of a movie
Doctor Strange disappointment
Jurassic world Dominion
oh talk I
broke my heart I mean I
Jurassic Park is one of the greatest
Blockbusters of all time
have that on record it's one of the best
movies it's like seeing dinosaurs come
to life for the first time
but the characters every character
you're connected with
the the kids weren't annoying you
actually like you got into the kids you
were like you you felt the sense of
wonder that they felt watching them you
felt the fear the panic
it was like the ultimate like
Blockbuster you just you couldn't
look away from that movie and it's
amazing how 25 years later you can still
watch that movie and it holds up and and
Steven Spielberg really one of his
crowning achievements as a filmmaker
and
Jurassic Park Dominion uh 100 one of the
most disappointing if not the most
disappointing movie that I seen at 2022
so far
they had all these great trailers
leading up to this movie which like
threw in the Legacy characters you get
all these characters back from the
original movie you're like oh my God
this has this great story to build upon
about we're gonna we're gonna finally
see dinosaurs and humans living together
that's what we've been promised
and it just goes back and does the same
thing over and over again
and the characters have not a single
brain cell in their freaking heads I I
it's just a dialogue terrible editing
uh just what a what a disaster what a
disaster and then you know Thor you know
again it's fun enough
but
compared to what we've seen before like
it's it's no black panther it's no
Guardians
it doesn't have that I mean top gun
Maverick right now is is that is the
movie that is saving the summer
and the uh the the the again going back
to Indies
is Indie movies better this year 100
with Marcel the Shell coming out and the
other great movie everything everywhere
all at once those are some great movies
and that's why you're seeing more and
more audiences kind of seeing those
movies because they're good
it's got off the top of your head one of
the biggest movies that have gone
straight to streaming coda
boom
Mitchell's versus the machines
that's probably all oh I mean Chip and
Dale Rescue Rangers I think is is a good
example of that too
um
but yeah I mean
there's a to me as someone who loves
movies
most movies that end up on streaming
don't have all the elements
that make them worthy of going to the
movie theater I mean
I think we would have seen coda in a
movie theater if it wasn't for the
pandemic
but I think a lot of these movies again
I I don't mean to crap on Netflix when I
say this is that Netflix to me is the
most guilty of all this
is that they have movies so many movies
that have right elements
but they never have the movie they never
have the movie that embodies everything
so Irishmen there's a great movie there
not at three hours
there's a great movie there somewhere
out too
it's like you have to have control of
that Meg there's a great movie there
don't know where it is it's lost
somewhere but they have them they just
need to kind of like have more
I know we want creative control for our
filmmakers but you have to sometimes
look at a cut of a movie and kind of say
this doesn't work even a movie like the
prom which is is I would say is a
streaming movie that I actually
really wished went to movie theaters
that movie is even 20 minutes too long
and I think there's a struggle with a
lot of streaming platforms is this
creative freedom of being able to make
the movement that they want
but it doesn't really hold up
to a a movie goer because there's
there's elements to it that maybe we as
film critics or industry professionals
like the fact that oh yeah look at this
he really had the time to fill out the
scene and like it goes on and yeah like
that works but to an average person
you're gonna watch this again like why
is the same stuff going I'm so bored
like come on move this along
and I think that's something that's that
struggles a lot with streaming movies
the one thing that I will say
positively about Netflix with streaming
is that they really have
reinvented the romantic comedy
what they have done for that genre is is
great because they they
inspired a group of young filmmakers to
kind of start off telling these these
cute rom-com movies
and that's something that we lost in the
Hollywood System there's so few good
rom-coms and I've watched so many of
them on Netflix and and even like the
other streaming platforms like Hulu had
one um
called The Fire Island a couple weeks
ago and that
that was really good too
best rom-com
[Music]
I mean we have to go with a classic
right When Harry Met Sally I mean Billy
Crystal Meg Ryan can't beat that and
then I guess closely followed up by
Pretty Woman
so it's been it's been a couple decades
then since yeah I mean they don't really
have I love rom-coms but like
they're not there's not that many of
them that feel all that special
speaking of which one it actually does
come to mind is set it up which is
actually a Netflix movie
and that's what Zoe Deutsch and Glenn
Powell I think that's one of the the
most Charming ones that I I've seen in
recent memory
how would you compare your excitement
level for streaming movies versus
theatrical movies
there's
[Music]
I know this contradicts something that I
said earlier about
you don't have to see every movie in a
theater
but there is something exciting about a
movie having a marketing campaign
so when you see a movie
and there's something to build towards
it
and seeing that on the big screen and
going to a movie theater and seeing a
poster or seeing a standing
it adds to it that gets really lost with
streaming movies
because
Bo Burnham jokes about this all the time
like there's
movies and TV shows and there's content
I feel like
a lot of what's on streaming is content
it's not really good enough to be
labeled as a movie or good enough to be
labeled as a TV show
but really like the kind of some stuff
that you would watch
just to pass the time
so while there have been some good stuff
both movies and TV shows on stream I
mean TV shows there's no question on
streaming platforms killing it I mean
movies on streaming platforms are not
there yet
TV shows are long past I mean some of
the best stuff that you can watch right
now are TV shows on streamers whether
it's Severance whether it's stranger
things
their squid game
they're there
movie wise theaters is still where it's
at and then every once in a while you'll
have the exception to a rule so to to
answer your question definitely
theatrical movies because of the
campaign there's a hype around it you
get excited you get oh my God a trailer
is dropping oh my God a poster dropped
oh my God casting news
you you get to see all of this and yes
you get the trades right about the
streaming movies and yes you get a
trailer for that but there's no event it
doesn't feel like anyone's coming in
coming together going to the movies is
an event
and when you have a movie whether it's a
Black Adam or a nope
that's like you just you feel it there's
a there's a build up to it you're like I
can't wait to see this I I can't wait oh
look there's a trailer coming out for
this the gray man oh okay I'll see it
when I see it
and also too the the half hour in the
theater before it starts when people are
finding their seats or nowadays we have
assigned seating and and there is
there's an anticipation
and and you also too kind of like look
around and I wonder how they're going to
react to it I wonder if they're gonna
like it you know are they gonna leave
you know yeah there's nothing like I
mean there's nothing like that and again
something about film festivals that make
it special
just like going to a Premiere going to a
film Film Festival is a very unique
experience because you're seeing a lot
of these things for the first time
so the reaction you're getting are very
natural
and you don't know what people are going
to expect they have really no trailers
going into the movie sometimes there's
not even images there's usually just a
plot description and maybe one image and
you walk into something and it's
completely clean you have no
expectations so in that in that regard
that's part of that experience that
makes it special but when we go to a
regular movie theater right it's the
crowd around you do they laugh at
certain moments do they cry at certain
moments are they reacting
and then trailers I mean I I hate to say
this but as much as I every time I get
an email about trailer I click on it and
I look at it on my phone
trailers play differently on the big
screen so when I sit there and I'm
watching 30 minutes of trailers
I'm really starting like sometimes I
really like oh wow that looked better
now like I watched it on my computer and
I was like but now I'm watching on the
big screen that looks great and other
times I kind of go oh yeah that looks
just as crappy here but at the same time
like that's something that is part of
the experience and you get to get to see
like oh
what am I going to get hyped up for next
you lose that on streaming once the
streaming movie ends right you get a
little thing on the bottom
do you want to watch dope sick I don't
know I don't know if I'm gonna watch
dope sick right now nah sorry but yeah
that's what it is you you almost like
the theatrical experience is so special
for so many reasons because it's a
shared experience but also
there's a build up to it you literally
get to go to a movie you get to see a
bunch of trailers and kind of go oh that
looks good and then you hear someone
else go that looks like
you know and it's and it's great it's
that but it it's it it sets up the next
one
I'm gonna come to the theater again to
see you know Black Adam all right great
what are you gonna see after blackout oh
look look they just showed a don't worry
darling trailer okay I'm gonna go see
that next you don't get that you don't
get that with streaming it's it's lost
it's lost and it also
the discovery of things
in Theatrical
is so much longer right it's like people
go to see movies multiple times in
theaters and they talk about it like oh
I went back to see Thor for the second
time
and I had a better experience or man
those those negatives that I had even
worse the second time around
streaming it's like people watch it once
and that's it they're done
and you're forced is this so important
so important about theatrical
is that you don't pause
you have to sit and you have to
experience it in one sitting you might
have to go to the bathroom and get up
and leave and miss something in the
movie
but you have to pay attention to it when
you're at home unless again so much
stuff is out there
you're gonna pause at nine time oh the
door's ringing hey you hungry you want a
snack let's go into the kitchen get that
you're really like if you want to snack
and then move there and you're really in
a really good movie there's like a pause
like I really want popcorn but this
movie's really good so I don't think I'm
gonna get up right now
so that's I think all those elements are
why theatrical is better
sure I mean they'd be a few times where
you're like you know what this is do it
Blockbuster tomorrow I'll watch it one
more time yeah I really want to get my
money's worth you know but but that was
rare yeah it was like one and done sort
of thing but I I agree yeah the street
the streaming stuff is just
there's so few things that I watched on
streaming where like I immediately have
a reaction of wanting to watch it again
it's just just very few and far between
what do you think about the gray man
having a is it a one-week theatrical run
yes okay so this is
Netflix's approach to playing nice and
nice with the theaters
um
I think
being a disrupter for so many years
has really kind of come back and bit
them in the ass
and again don't get me wrong
they've done so much in terms of content
and then TV shows
creating so many great iconic TV shows
you know their whole platform was pretty
much launched on House of Cards and
Orange is the New Black
but they really did set the bar of kind
of like we're gonna produce
our own movies we're going to produce
our own TV shows and they're going to be
on our platform and our platform only
and we own the rights to them and we
don't need theaters and we don't need
this
and they sort of had to figure out a
solution because they wanted to be part
of the awards conversation and the way
that they did it because of the Academia
rules is that they said you only have to
play in one theater in New York and L.A
and you have to play for a week
so they did the bare minimum
and when you start having movies
with these big actors whether it's red
notice
whether it's the gray man
you're not going to have that same
experience
watching it and on on Netflix at home as
you are in a theater
because these movies are made like these
are these are directors and stars who
like make movies that are there for
theater
you're you have you hire the Russo
brothers and you're gonna get one week
and it's not even playing at AMC or
Regal it's only playing at Cinemark
because
they haven't negotiated their contracts
yet of getting it because they don't
know what's going to happen and also
they disrupted the industry for so long
that people are like I don't think as
willing to play with them like they
don't they want to come to the sandbox
now and be like hey can I have a shovel
and I want to dig with you and people
are a little bit more resistant to it
and I think
sadly that does a lot of these movies a
great disservice because I think they
would play better when you when you have
a movie
like the power of the dog which
for the record I didn't care that much
about
but it has an audience it was the type
of movie that you would see at your
small independent theater I always use
the the Lemley and um Encino like the
one where like I feel like the
50-somethings always go to and like they
go to on an afternoon they sit there and
you know and Ginny and Bob sit there and
I go oh what do you want to see I feel
like that movie would have played there
for like months right it just would have
been like there for months and and they
would have went to see it and they would
have told you know Rosie and Jack to see
it and everyone would have came and seen
it you don't really have that with with
Netflix movies is that they get the the
one week
they come in and again
what's the
for people who are not like me who are
obsessed with movies and like the
experience people were just watching it
it's just another movie that's what we
often forget
it's just another movie it's just not
like as soon as you see this it's on to
the next one and the average person
doesn't care if they're watching on
their phone or that but again if you
want to create an experience
and you want more people talking about
it that's why theatrical is so important
and it's going to be I think it's going
to take a lot of a lot of time before
Netflix gets it they they're going to
try for knives out too that's that's the
one they have to push they already got
the green light to Premiere at
the Toronto International Film Festival
they're gonna have to really push that
for theatrical because the first one was
a theatrical movie and people know what
it is so they're gonna that's gonna be
their test run of how to get
people off the couch from watching
Netflix to theaters but I really do
wonder how many theaters are actually
going to play it
Scott what's the difference between
critique versus trolling
nowadays who knows
um
I I feel like some critics are almost
trolls at this point because once they
get their mind made up about things
they seem like they can
understand or respect someone else's
and I I really do feel like social media
is it's is the blame for that because
everyone has become an expert
and I think I'm probably
one of
part of the last generation where
I went to school for film criticism
and I studied film I grew up watching
film and I didn't just wake up one
morning and say you know tomorrow I'm
going to start a blog and I'm going to
write about movies and then everyone's
going to accept me as a Critic
I went to
school for it whether it was Chapman
University or Kutztown University where
I got my masters
and I studied film I studied Film
Production I studied film criticism I
spent years watching movies and and
reading books about it
and in the last
15 years that almost like kind of went
out the window because
and I I will say that I think YouTube
was the start of it
YouTube allowed and I know as part of
this initial buzz on YouTube
allowed the everyday person to be able
to record a video and give their opinion
on something sure you had live Journal
beforehand
or Myspace or whatever
but YouTube kind of was this thing that
caught on and nothing has been able to
to over overtake it right I mean out of
all the videos Platforms in the world
YouTube has has holds held strong for 15
years
but I remember this because
I remember watching a lot of people who
are my colleagues now
doing YouTube video reviews
whether it was the smose Christian and
Mark whether it was Jeremy Johns Chris
stuckman
and they are all kind of people who felt
this love
of movies
but they their their whole selling point
was
where the average Joe we're the you know
the smallest thing was always we're the
spouse we're the average guy
we're not the film critics we're not the
hoity Twitty and I think for a period of
time it was great because there was a
group of them who I think did their
homework and they were really
prioritize in doing this but then the
floodgates opened
and everyone who liked movies
decided that they were going to become
a movie reviewer
and I think we're going to do it as a
career
so we turned into an industry where so
many people
are
putting their time and effort
into film and criticism
that number one don't really have a long
history of it they have no backing they
have no schooling behind it
but I think the most
troubling part of all this is
who don't make money from it
so
there's only so many jobs just like
there's only so many movies and so many
acting roles and so many directing roles
and whatnot
there's only so many places for
film critics
and with newspapers kind of falling
and going away
you don't have as many critics working
for those sources anymore so you have
trades
you saw what happened to Entertainment
Weekly they're now all digital
all these websites that popped up
they're all digital some of them went
under but got sold to other companies
they keep getting sold over and over and
over again
so there's a very limited amount of
space that people can actually critique
stuff
and yet everyone feels like they want
their voice heard so they create their
own blog or their own movie website
and then they get
in a weird way they get devastated
because they're like oh I can't make a
living this is what I love I want to do
it right and
then you got people doing gofundme's and
kickstarters and all this stuff to kind
of like hey I want to go this event I
want to go here can you give me money to
do this
and these people don't have
money they can they can't support
themselves and they want to do this so
it's like it's weird in a weird way like
when I was growing up we always remember
seeing actors and everyone always ever
hearing everyone like I I know I talked
about Jim Carrey
Jim Carrey like sleeping in his car and
he wanted to be an actor right he just
he knew he wanted to be an actor and the
struggle of that
it's weird because now we're like film
critics where they're like we'll do
anything for it and it's very strange
but
I realized I didn't answer the question
about trolls versus film film critics
to me
a troll is someone who like loves
something
and like hates anyone who has a
different opinion of that and will kind
of seek out
and want to destroy a person
for not sharing the same view or the
same love that they have for something
a Critic should be able to look at
something subjectively
regardless of whether they like
an actor an actress
a filmmaker and judge a full product
and look at it and say
is the script good is the score good is
the production design good is the acting
good
and be able to kind of call out the
weaknesses and the strengths
of whatever that project is
and I think there's a very big
difference because I've noticed
fandom has gone so far past
just being a Star Wars movie or Star
Wars TV show or DC
it's gone to like individual people like
I cannot tell you how many times I have
been attacked
by people who I don't mind as actors or
I like as actors but I don't like
something they do
and like this Hive mentality comes after
you like the last the most recent one
was Lady Gaga this past year for House
of Gucci
I love Lady Gaga I think Lady Gaga is a
gifted singer she's a great actress
how's the Gucci just didn't showcase her
strongest moments and it was kind of
laughably bad at times
you put that out and it's like they just
don't freak and they come at you oh you
like Kristen Stewart how dare you she's
a terrible actress and it's like they
find everything they can
to use against you
and it's just it's like this so mean
spirited and so much hate
that it's almost like
after a while
it works against them because like you
actually now have like this negative
reaction towards this person because
their fans are so shitty towards you
because you're like I like this person I
just didn't like this one thing and all
these people are like sitting here
attacking me now
and like you almost want to like would
they don't seem to realize too is that
the people doing this we usually have
the opportunity at some point whether
it's at an award show whether it's in a
junket to talk to these to these talents
so it's weird because I think if I ever
talk to Lady Gaga I think I would say to
her
you know probably at the end of the
interview or something like that I said
by the way
you know do you realize how shitty your
fans are
because like I literally said I didn't
like you in one thing but I still
support you and I still think you're
great in these other things and these
people came out at me sending me you
know death threats and like calling me
like the worst person on the planet and
all this stuff so I think that's that's
the really big difference is that as as
a Critic
even if you love someone
you have to be able to acknowledge that
they're not going to be on their game
all the time
you know I love Tim Burton as a director
but
sometimes he doesn't make good movies
Alice in Wonderland not a good movie
Dark Shadows not a good movie doesn't
mean I hate Tim Burton it just means
those movies didn't work and that
happens with everything you can be a
Marvel fan and think that Thor is a
terrible movie you can be a Marvel fan
and and hate Ant-Man it doesn't matter
like you can still love the product and
the brand
they're never gonna nothing's perfect in
this world you're never gonna have a 10
out of 10 every time
and I think people need to understand
that I think that's the importance of
criticism is that you have to be able to
look at an individual
film
and judge it on its own Merit it's it's
not about
this person's body of work like I'm
going to judge all of Leonardo DiCaprio
just because he was in you know
Shutter Island that's it that's it
that's the movie I'm judging him on no
you have to look at everyone and all
they've done but also look at the
individual project and judge that on its
own
has trolling become a hobby
yes a lot of them go too far and
sometimes
you get caught up in the moment of it
right like it's very weird as
someone who is a fan of of people who
are popular within the industry uh
whether it's a Taylor Swift a Kristen
Stewart or Tim Burton
um Steven Spielberg whoever
you you almost like when they have
something you want to Champion you're
almost like you almost become
part of the the you know the hive we
were talking about the hive you almost
become part of that Hive because
I wanted Kristen Stewart so badly to win
the Oscar right that like even though
all the signs were pointing in the in
the direction that likes does not
happening right she's not established
enough she doesn't have enough people in
the industry don't like her like all
these things are pointed in the
direction that she was gonna do it yet
like you believe so strongly in the
person and you want to Champion them so
hard
is that like
you have to like Let It Go and the thing
is and that's the difference that I
think between
regular like critics and and journalists
and and people who are fans versus
trolls is that you can support someone
and you can like literally post about
them every day if you love them that
much
but at the end of the time like there's
got to be a point where you can cut it
off
so like okay Kristen Stewart lost she
didn't win the Oscar
you can't sit there for the next year
posting about like oh she should have
won every day and there's people who do
and I think it's very very unhealthy
that people become so obsessed
with celebrities and films and pop stars
and all this stuff because
you have to have focus elsewhere it's
just what you need to fo you know you
need to have like a life outside of
these things these are these are
I don't even know how to put it but
these are
these are moments in your life right
like seeing a movie exists in in that
moment for the two hours or two and a
half hours
and you can like you can like it and you
can talk about it and until you're blue
in the face but you have to have
something else you have to have
something else you look for whether it's
a partner whether it's going out to eat
whether it's going to play sports you
have to and I'm really kind of worried
about some of
those in this in this industry and
especially the trolls who seem like they
don't have anything else to do with
their time and they have no other
Ambitions but to sit here
and like support someone who I hate to
say it probably doesn't even know you
exist and even if they know you exist
they meet you they say hi
they're thankful that you're supporting
them
but they're going home afterwards and
they're not going to say for the next
six months thinking about oh there's
Julie I remember remember Julie we met
Julia that's screening and she was so
sweet I'm going to talk about Julie
every day for six like no she's
literally like okay met a really nice
guy you know met that really nice guy
there had a great moment with him he was
really nice that's it come up in
conversation once ever you know that's
it
what do you think of critics who go out
of their way to bash movies is that
being brutally honest and people just
tell it like it is or is there an
element of wanting to wound somebody
it depends on the person
I feel like there's
certain critics
who literally have an out
for certain filmmakers certain producers
certain actors
that no matter what they do
they won't give them like an inch it's
just like ah this guy
you know you always hear the the
expression white man keeps falling
upward you know and I mean the industry
is very guilty of that right like
there's a there's a lot of
white men in this industry who have made
some really shitty movies that just keep
getting to make shitty movies
and
I think it's okay to call people out if
they kind of proven themselves time and
time again like if you're going like
past a three or four time and you're
like still making a something that's not
good and we kind of have this you know
Universal decision
that like this is not a good movie and
you're not a good director maybe it's
time to push that person to the side and
give someone else
but I do feel like
a good actor
could meet a good director
and it could be
a game changer
someone who like has been bad
as an actor
could have a great script with a gray
filmmaker and they can turn that person
to a star
I mean there's so many people
like within comedy
um I I really don't like the way the
comedy has become over the last like
decade where everything's kind of like
over sexualized and it's grossed out
humor and like
in buckets and forwarding and
all this stuff like all these like kids
playing with dildos all this like really
like grotesque like infantile stuff and
you know people have been embracing it
because like oh now it's females doing
isn't it funny because it's a female
shooting in a bucket it's like nah it
wasn't funny when the guy was doing it
it's definitely not funny when the
woman's doing it like no it doesn't work
but you get to see certain actors like
evolve and I mean
great examples for me are a lot of
comedic actors right
you can take an Adam Sandler or you can
take a Jim Carrey and I'm gonna go use
those two because those are people who I
grew up with and and I love Jim Carrey
but watching Jim Carrey like there's a
bunch of people who hated Jim Carrey and
his brand of humor
right so they're seeing all his movies
they see the ice Ventura now this is
stupid dumb and dumber such stupid stuff
and then you get to see him in Truman
Show
and you get to see a different side of
him
and it just changes everything you just
you hear your perspective of Jim can't
carry has changed and you see this whole
different sign so Flash Forward to like
recent years
seeing people like Seth Rogen move away
from kind of the Knocked Up thing to do
like more serious dramas or roles that
are comedic but are more mature Jonah
Hill like watching him kind of like in a
super bad and then seeing him in like
Wolf of Wall Street or Moneyball
I couldn't stand Jonah Hill and those
move like super bad and and and uh oh my
God what's the other one like the sitter
all those movies where he was doing all
those comedies and then he said
Moneyball and I'm like who's this guy
like why is he so good and then Wolf of
Wall Street
you really you gotta find it very
interesting you got to give people
chances and they're not you're not
always going to be fan and you may never
be a fan of that person but in the right
hands uh an actor could who you think
might be mediocre not good could
contract you know transcend everything
you ever thought of that person you
might fall in love with them
so when it comes to critics I think it's
really hard because
I do think that people feel a very
strong Vendetta towards certain
filmmakers or CERN actors
and they they kind of want to poo them
like they always want them to fail and
I'm not saying that that's a big portion
of them but there are definitely people
who like oh you really really hate this
person and every time you see them like
we know Point Blank that this is going
to be a negative reveal and I think
that's problematic because in as I said
in film criticism the most important
thing to be is subjective and
open-minded you need to go into anything
if a trailer looks bad if everything
looks like it's going to be terrible you
know I'm not moving and it might
surprise you and you have to admit that
you're wrong
and if you like something that other
people don't like you can also admit
that and not be afraid of it because a
lot of people are afraid of not agreeing
what the general consensus
what should matter more to a film critic
being popular or being right
um
probably every video that people are
going to watch is like depends on who
you ask
to me
I don't know I don't really like that
question because
it shouldn't be right
and it shouldn't be about popularity
it should be about
how that movie worked for you and why
why did that movie work why is that a
good movie and explaining why you think
that's a good movie
to me there should be no popularity in
film criticism like you shouldn't and
that that's a problem in itself and a
tangent that I can go on about how
the industry picks
20 people to see stuff always first
and every time they see something it's
either going to be a glowing review or
they won't tweet and to me it's so
problematic and everyone calls them out
and everyone knows and they work for
Outlets that get all the access in the
world
and they can't publicly say it they know
it it's because what people will not
tell you about criticism
is that when you when you work for a
company
that the foundation of your job is built
on selling this stuff
you saying something bad about it and if
it's your job to do the junk it right
afterwards and sit down with the talent
the talent is not going to sit down with
you if you say something is bad or you
really Hammer a movie or you you really
go in on it
they're not and this is something that I
don't know why everyone is so afraid of
so when you unless you're separating the
person doing the interview from the
person who's doing the review
there is unfortunately a bias that is
creative that you can either own up and
say you know what I did not like this
so I'm not going to say anything because
I know I have the junk it
or you just kind of have to like pass
the buck and be like you know what I
feel really strongly about this I really
don't like this so I'm gonna have to
like save my piece
and then if I if it cost me this
it cost me this but there's a financial
thing
and I don't mean to throw any Outlet
underneath the bus but like when you
look at trades whether it's variety
Hollywood Reporter
deadline
or you look at something like Fandango
is the person who works at Fandango
going to screen a movie
and come out of it and say oh that was
terrible
as the initial reaction of like when
he's one of the first people to sing it
when he worked for a site whose job it
is to sell tickets
and so many people in this industry are
struggling
that they rely on such dual jobs of like
not just doing criticism anymore but
also like pitching a story to do a
write-up of like the behind the scenes
of this movie that
they can't
say things because if they
publicist the personal publicist the
studio publicist sees this they have the
potential of losing it
people want to be moderators
people want to be moderate just get paid
good money to moderate a panel
do you think that person is going to get
the job if they don't like the movie
no so there's there's so many different
layers to everything now and I think
it's just it's it's exposed more because
of all of the stuff that we see right
because of the social media and all this
stuff and you just kind of see the same
names like when we were growing up
when I was growing up and I I you know I
saw a name on a trailer right it didn't
think to me like
why is that same person being quoted all
the time like it was like always the
same couple people and now it's the same
thing where it's the same names you know
so like you almost after a while you
kind of understand like there's people
that they can go to who can kind of say
hey we need a quote give us a quote
so there's just so many aspects of this
industry that are very difficult but
when it comes to being popular versus
being right
I mean I don't think they have any place
in criticism you know because
you're right in your opinion your
opinion is right no one should be able
to change that if you like something you
like something as long as you can
explain why you like something that's
right to who you are as a person and to
be popular I don't know like I again
it's a weird fandom thing like film
critics have their own fandom like I
it's weird now like right like when we
were growing up there was the greats
right we had Leonard Maul and we had
Cisco and Ebert
yeah yeah there's a couple other people
and they were just about a very small
group because they were kind of ones
that like everyone knew of they had TV
shows or whatever and you you were very
familiar but like now there's so many
and it's like social media like the guy
who runs I don't know I'm again I'm not
trying to like narrow and point things
out but like the guy who runs
comicbook.com like oh my God I love that
guy it's like the guy runs comicbook.com
like his his job is to like talk about
comic book movies and when they're not
that same guy
who's gonna go see
Black Adam and he's going to talk to
Dwayne Johnson
he's not going to be able to come out of
Black Adam and be like oh man that movie
sucks like what am I doing like what a
waste of my time because he knows two
days later he's gonna be sitting down
with Dwayne Johnson talking about it
because that's the next piece of article
that's going on there and and the trades
are even worse because of the fact that
they their whole business is selling ads
and revenues and telling stories
so I I just I my eyes have been opened
and I have forever changed the way I
look at all of this moving out here I
never knew any of this until I moved out
here eight years ago and that really
changed changed how I view a lot of this
stuff and it's very hard because I try
very hard to be a genuine person and I
like what I like and I and I don't feel
bad about what I like and I and stuff I
don't like it's very hard because you
are often criticized
if you go too hard on something
and it's just again it's my personal
feeling so but I don't go out of the way
there's there's a difference between
people who go out of their way to slam
something over and over and over and
over again someone else likes it enjoy
it that's fine I just want my peace and
if someone asks me about I'm going to
make my my anger or my love of something
very well known so fairness in the
criticism versus just trying to just
constantly bring like thinking it's your
right to bring someone down because
there is that angle online as well and
and so going back to let's say you talk
about Jonah Hill maybe you weren't the
exact fan of him right in comedic roles
but then when you saw him in two more
serious roles you're like you know what
I like this guy and and it's do you you
know did you go out of your way to slam
him I doubt yeah I mean you don't I mean
I think it's like again it's it's the
level of which you go for it right you
can be very vocal about you don't like a
director you don't like an act you don't
like a pop star you don't like a sports
figure you don't like whatever
but there's a point there's a crossroads
right when you're going out of your way
like and this is what we were talking
about was trolls
when you go out of your way to start
seeking people
and like tearing them down
and like there are people who I know
who if they don't like something they
will go on everyone's posts social media
Facebook Instagram and be like you're
wrong you suck what are you doing you're
the worst critic ever you're the worst
you know what does this take blah blah
you were bought by Marvel you're brought
by DC you were bought by Star Wars
you're bought by Disney whatever
that's where you cross the line right
you can just say man I totally
saw this differently and I again I think
it's it's something about there's a fine
line like you can be movies have this
strange
way and I think it's all entertainment
it has a strange way of connecting with
people when you see a good movie
and it connects with you you want to get
up you want to
share you want to celebrate it you want
to tell all your friends to see it you
probably you know us weird people who
get obsessed with these things you don't
want to stop talking about it you just
want to keep championing it I mean I I
go back to my Coda example like I saw
that movie at Sundance on a virtual
screening link as soon as I was able to
see it in a theater I saw it in a
theater and then I went to multiple
press events for whether I was
moderating it or part of it or not I
went back and I saw it and I just
because I wanted to support the movie
and like if people were like oh you're
being such a shield it's like no no
if I was doing this for every Apple
release or every Disney release or every
DC release then I would be a shell
but because I'm literally picking
something that resonated with me that I
love and I want to Champion there's a
difference and that's what people don't
seem to get you can like something that
a company puts out and hate the next
thing and I always use this as a great
example because
I did not like tragedy and Macbeth and
that was the other movie that was Apple
was pushing with Coda and they tried to
get me it to see that movie again and I
told the Reps I will not
watch that movie again and they were
like come on Denzel Washington and I'm
like if I'm going to meet Denzel
Washington for the first time I wanted
to be a movie where I can walk up to him
and be like Denzel you're amazing and
this movie's amazing not like you're
amazing but like can we talk about
training day or something else because I
don't want to talk about this
from the game pitch storm that we have
here uh we're going to present you with
a few character descriptions and plot
lines and we'd like to see what movies
come to mind I'm going to read a few uh
the first one is character
and the character trait is a journalist
on the trail of a huge story
first thing you can in mind spotlight
Spotlight uh
let's see what else All the President's
Men
the post
[Music]
it's a movie oh my God what is that his
name event Pelican Brief or no no that's
different no honest thing uh Aaron
Brockovich
yeah so those those would be the ones
that come to mind for that right right
state of play
Russell oh my God yeah yeah that was so
good yeah it was yeah it was good okay
okay wonderful love it um here is
another uh character
Suave art Thief
oceans movie doesn't matter which one
um
Mordecai can I say Mordecai as as weird
as that sounds uh I would say Mordecai
and Oceans 11 12 13 1700 uh
oh DaVinci Code
Bean there you go Bean
and uh
that's it
did you see American animals
yes but I would never have thought you
would never thought okay
yeah but I would have never thought of
that okay I saw that at Sundance too I
love that film yeah it's so great okay
um a fiery young rapper on their way to
fame
Eight Mile done film I really don't have
any other answers besides that a mile
okay okay great
uh all right a troubled kid with
supernatural abilities
Spider-Man
[Music]
Batman
Wonder Woman
[Laughter]
foreign oh my God
powder powder it's going back
that's going back a ways that director
got canceled by the way you can't you
can't like powder anymore okay I'm sorry
because it's the same director who did
Jeepers Creepers I'm pretty sure well
Sean Patrick Flannery
plot okay with our little game here and
here we go battles corruption in the
greeting card industry
foreign
oh my God
is that that's not
I know what the movie is but I can't
think of it
I'm gonna have to pass okay I can't name
it either I don't know it doesn't have
the answer no it doesn't oh my God I was
like there is a movie that is about
greeting cards and I'm like trying to
think what it is like all the writers
are sitting in the room thinking about
greeting cards and I cannot remember
what for the life of me what that movie
is
okay well hopefully in the comments
someone can um yes put the right one
okay races around the world in a hot air
balloon
Around the World in 80 Days done that's
that's the only one I can think of okay
is mistakenly sent to heaven
Kenneth at the end of the South Park
movie
um
oh what was that other one wasn't there
there's a Chris Rock movie that I can't
remember
the title of but there was a down to
earth right it's down to earth I guess
that's the opposite so he didn't get
sent to Heaven he came down there
um but yeah it was a John Travolta movie
too I think oh yes Michael yeah okay
Michael Michael yes he's like the sort
of the the snarky Angel that's right
that was a good 90s yep I like that yeah
yeah so my references are going back a
few years here but okay goes undercover
in the world of hip-hop culture
21 Jump Street I guess both of those 21
Jump Street 22 Jump Street
oh my god there was that terrible
Jamie movie most America's Most Wanted
or Most Wanted I don't remember Jamie
Kennedy movie from like the late 90s
um I feel like there was a parody movie
about this as well
Dance Flick or something I don't know
okay I couldn't name one so you're doing
better than I am okay competes in a
deadly reality TV competition
first movie that comes to mind is the
God Bless America
second one was
I think it's called series seven the
contenders
I mean squid game of course comes to
mind now even though it's not really the
same and so does Hunger Games even
though they're not really the same
and of course Battle Royale
um but that's it okay here's another
discovers a dangerous Secret at a
popular new theme park
uh escape from Tomorrowland
remember that movie oh
that was the undercover uh Disney movie
that they did it was a big thing at
Sundance they went into Disneyland and
they filmed the entire movie
with like portable
camcorders and they told some kind of
story around it it was like all the like
the dark secrets of like Disneyland it's
a very bizarre movie I did not like it
but it it always sticks in my mind
whenever someone says something about
amusement parks that one always comes to
my mind
and I did like the horror movie that was
at
Six Flags I can't remember the name of
that was it came out a couple years ago
fright night maybe not Friday
something else I can't remember
okay discovers the Fountain of Youth
Keanu Reeves movie
um I feel like multiple ones from like
the 90s
cocoon
foreign
[Laughter]
oh my gosh that wow that's a tough one
no I can't think of anything else yeah
well oh no big that's not really the
Fountain of Youth because yeah that's
that's not it but okay Freaky Friday if
you're gonna go that route I mean
searches for peace in a dangerous
radioactive Wasteland
Toxic Avenger
there you go one for all the cult
favorites
fighting against evil robots that look
like people
AI
me really comes to mind
is iRobot also qualify for that I guess
so and then
that's it yeah because I mean it
wouldn't be chappy that doesn't make any
sense oh yeah he was he was way too nice
yeah way too nice sweet guy
I'm hoping to get your thoughts on this
I found a 2017 article in the financial
review about Steven Spielberg and the
writer says few great film directors are
as picked on as Steven Spielberg and
then the article continues to say partly
this is down to his outsized success
which sits ill at ease with our notion
of an artist
I find that interesting do you think
success brings a distrust of the artist
after a while
it brings more criticism
for sure because
when you have someone
like Steven Spielberg
who raised the bar so much very early on
I mean Jaws
what that did for like the horror movie
genre
you know and it still talked about to
this day
Jurassic Park
Schindler's List
the older he gets
the projects he takes on they're not as
many home runs or they're not as
consistent
but I think he's making movies that are
more
what he wants to do he's kind of earned
the right to make the movies that he
wants to make
and that piece makes me immediately
think of West Side Story
because
there was so much criticism around West
Side Story
and I'm not saying that they were wrong
but there is a lot of criticism with the
Latino culture about how they were
presented in the movie and how a certain
filmmaker should have been directing
that movie
but I think he's at a point where he's
kind of a legacy director and he's
earned his stripes
that if you're a studio
and Steven Spielberg walks into your
office and goes hey I want to remake
West Side Story
I don't really think anyone's going to
turn him down right and I think people
forget about that
and it there is a discussion to be had
there about
whether certain filmmakers really should
be tackling certain topics and whether
other filmmakers would be better suited
for that
but I do think
you kind of earn your right to do a lot
of stuff when you've proven yourself so
much and so much of film history
is centered around what you have
accomplished I mean Close Encounters I
mean
Indiana Jones like there's so much stuff
that he has been a part of
that you can't take away from it's just
like you kind of get a pass you kind of
get to do what you want but I do think
that the older
a director becomes
the more criticism he faces and you you
don't have to just use Steven Spielberg
look at Martin Scorsese how many how
many people have been
criticizing him more
Clint Eastwood yeah how many people
criticize him now
I mean Woody Allen for other reasons but
I mean Woody Allen has always been
sort of a one-no filmmaker right it's
always a rich social lights getting
together for something he's been making
the same movie since the 80s but only
because of the controversy around him
the people start being like oh he's not
that good of a director it's like I
don't know he's like literally making
the same movie over and over again like
so if this is not good and then those
other movies weren't that good either
so yeah I I think at the end of the day
that's that's really what it comes down
to is that I think it's easy to become a
punching bag
but it's even more easy to be a punching
bag in a modern age when you're an older
white guy
it's something that I've I definitely
noticed people are not afraid to throw
older white men underneath the bus
anymore
and in terms of the the scope of West
Side Story I mean there were a lot of
cast members right so to give this to a
newer director
uh would be I mean this is someone who's
directed large-scale production so not
just his name but also expertise
I mean some some would argue that he
didn't have a background in musicals
um you know again
the story the subject matter is very
sensitive and it's again as you're
talking about a movie that came out
originally in the 50s
and people have problems with that
regardless of whether uh Rita Morano is
in it they still have problems with the
way that that story was told and people
still view it as a classic but again
like a lot of movies made in different
Generations they don't necessarily
are up to par with the way things are
today
and I think that's the problem I think
if if Steven Spielberg wanted to remake
West Side Story in the 90s
the approach and the criticism on it
would have been a lot different sure
nowadays it's sort of like no why didn't
like
lin-manuel Miranda direct that he would
have been a much better director he's
Latino he would have gotten the
storyline he would have gave him more
emotion you know in that movie also on
unfairly got a lot of hate because of
the whole Ansel Elgort thing
and people criticizing them for like
nobody going and bashing him on that
tour which is like
I think people forget that just because
one person does something crappy to one
person
doesn't mean that he's crappy to
everyone you know this is not a Harvey
Weinstein situation on our hands
and sometimes people can get called out
and they can learn from their mistakes
and it also depends on the person's age
he's a young guy
we make a lot of bad decisions when
we're in high school and college sure
and he probably just made a bad decision
so as long as he learns from it and
grows from it it's fine but that movie I
didn't love that movie but I feel like
that movie really got like the end
of the stick I don't know I don't know
how else to put it because I feel like
it was just always on the chopping block
for so many people
and so going forward maybe younger
directors who are earning their stripes
is that something that they will have to
face that that they will be once you get
to be a certain level now you're just
you you have a Target on your back
basically
I mean it's so hard how everyone turns
on someone now right like
we saw it with Patty Jenkins with 1984.
everyone loved Wonder Woman everyone
loved monster
and then all of a sudden everyone turned
like we we forget that
filmmakers and actors
they're not perfect they take roles they
make movies that sometimes don't work or
they don't connect they don't resonate
and it's so weird because I don't know
how to answer that question because I
almost feel like it is dependent on a
person
like are people going to turn on Jordan
peel if nope is not good I don't know
and and then it becomes this weird
conversation about
is it a race thing is it a sexual
orientation thing is it what the person
stands for like are we like because
Jordan peel is such a
inspiring filmmaker and someone who's so
ambitious and takes chances and made two
movies that were very critically
acclaimed
is it okay because he's a person of
color who puts other people of color in
his movies for nope and I'm not saying I
don't know I haven't seen it but if nope
is not good
will he get the pass because of all the
other things he he's done or will people
turn on him and be like
I'll guess that gravy trains over this
guy is a terrible filmmaker what a
terrible movie
it's so hard to know anymore because you
watch everyone turn so quickly on
someone and it doesn't matter what it is
it's really weird time to be in this
industry because you say one thing wrong
and and a whole entire group of people
can turn against you
make one bad film and it's like they
lost it
it's crazy I don't know I mean it's it's
such a it's such a weird way to think
because
we started this question with Steven
Spielberg
and I mean Steven Spielberg has
consistently made
a good movie and a bad movie a good
movie and a bad movie a good movie in a
bad movie
it's just the way that it is and again
it's all subjective
film
all art is subjective what's bad to some
might be good to someone else